The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: --of
our limiting distribution,
which happen to be Gaussian.
But if the central
limit theorem told
us that the limiting
distribution of some average
was something that
looked like a Poisson
or an [? exponential, ?]
then we would just
have in the same way
taken the quintiles
of the exponential distribution.
So let's go back to what we had.
So generically if you have a
set of observations X1 to Xn.
So remember for the kiss example
they were denoted by R1 to Rn,
because they were turning
the head to the right,
but let's just go back.
We say X1 to Xn,
and in this case
I'm going to assume
they're IID, and I'm
going to make them Bernoulli
with [INAUDIBLE] p,
and p is unknown, right?
So what did we do from here?
Well, we said p is
the expectation of Xi,
and actually we didn't even
think about it too much.
We said, well, if
I need to estimate
the proportion of people who
turn their head to the right
when they kiss, I
just basically I'm
going to compute the average.
So our p hat was just
Xn bar, which was just 1
over n sum from i
over 1 2n of the Xi.
The average of the observations
was their estimate.
And then we wanted to build
some confidence intervals
around this.
So what we wanted to understand
is, how much that this p hat
fluctuates.
This is a random variable.
It's an average of
random variables.
It's a random
variable, so we want
to know what the
distribution is.
And if we know what
the distribution is,
then we actually know,
well, where it fluctuates.
What the expectation is.
Around which value it tends
to fluctuate et cetera.
And so what the
central limit theorem
told us was if I take square
root of n times Xn bar minus p,
which is its average.
And then I divide it by
the standard deviation.
Then this thing here converges
as n goes to infinity,
and we will say
a little bit more
about what it means
in distribution
to some standard
normal random variable.
So that was the
central limit theorem.
So what it means is
that when I think
of this as a random variable,
when n is large enough
it's going to look like this.
And so I understand
perfectly its fluctuations.
I know that this
thing here has--
I know the probability
of being in this zone.
I know that this
number here is 0.
I know a bunch of things.
And then, in
particular, what I was
interested in was that
the probability, that's
the absolute value of a
Gaussian random variable,
exceeds q alpha over
2, q alpha over 2.
We said that this
was equal to what?
Anybody?
What was that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Alpha, right?
So that's the probability.
That's my random variable.
So this is by definition q
alpha over 2 is the number.
So that to the right
of it is alpha over 2.
And this is a negative q
alpha over 2 by symmetry.
And so the probability
that i exceeds-- well,
it's not very symmetric,
but the probability
that i exceeds this
value, q alpha over 2,
is just the sum of
the two gray areas.
All right?
So now I said that this thing
was approximately equal,
due to the central
limit theorem,
to the probability,
that square root of n.
Xn bar minus p divided by
square root p 1 minus p.
Well, absolute value was
larger than q alpha over 2.
Well, then this thing by default
is actually approximately equal
to alpha, just because of virtue
of the central limit theorem.
And then we just said,
well, I'll solve for p.
Has anyone attempted to solve
the degree two equation for p
in the homework?
Everybody has tried it?
So essentially, this is
going to be an equation in p.
Sometimes we don't
want to solve it.
Some of the p's we will replace
by their worst possible value.
For example, we said one
of the tricks we had was
that this value here,
square root of p 1 minus p,
was always less than one half.
Until we could actually get
the confidence interval that
was larger than all
possible confidence
intervals for all
possible values of p,
but we could solve for p.
Do we all agree on the
principle of what we did?
So that's how you build
confidence intervals.
Now let's step
back for a second,
and see what was important in
the building of this confidence
interval.
The really key thing is
that I didn't tell you
why I formed this thing, right?
We started from
x bar, and then I
took some weird function of x
bar that depended on p and n.
And the reason is, because
when I take this function,
the central limit
theorem tells me
that it converges to
something that I know.
But this very important thing
about the something that I know
is that it does not depend on
anything that I don't know.
For example, if I
forgot to divide
by square root of p 1 minus
p, then this thing would have
had a variance, which
is the p 1 minus p.
If I didn't remove this
p here, the mean here
would have been affected by p.
And there's no table
for normal p 1.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh, so
the square root of n terms
come from.
So really you should view this.
So there's a rule and sort
of a quiet rule in math
that you don't write a
divided by b over c, right?
You write c times a divided
by b, because it looks nicer.
But the way you want
to think about this
is that this is x bar minus p
divided by the square root of p
1 minus p divided by n.
And the reason is,
because this is actually
the standard deviation of this--
oh sorry, x bar n.
This is actually the standard
deviation of this guy,
and the square root of n comes
from the [INAUDIBLE] average.
So the key thing
was that this thing,
this limiting distribution
did not depend on anything
I don't know.
And this is actually called
a pivotal distribution.
It's pivotal.
I don't need anything.
I don't need to know anything,
and I can read it in a table.
Sometimes there's going
to be complicated things,
but now we have computers.
The beauty about Gaussian is
that people have studied them
to death, and you can
open any stats textbook,
and you will see a table
again that will tell you
for each value of alpha
you're interested in,
it will tell you what
q alpha over 2 is.
But there might be some
crazy distributions,
but as long as they
don't depend on anything,
we might actually
be able to simulate
from them, and in particular
compute what q alpha over 2
is for any possible
value [INAUDIBLE]..
And so that's what we're
going to be trying to do.
Finding pivotal distributions.
How do we take this Xn bar,
which is a good estimate,
and turn it into something
which may be exactly
or asymptotically
does not depend
on any unknown parameter.
So here is one way
we can actually--
so that's what we did for
the kiss example, right?
And here I mentioned,
for example,
in the extreme case,
when n was equal to 3
we would get a different
thing, but here the CLT
would not be valid.
And what that means is that
my pivotal distribution
is actually not the
normal distribution,
but it might be something else.
And I said we can make
take exact computations.
Well, let's see
what it is, right?
If I have three observations,
so I'm going to have X1, X2, X3.
So now I take the
average of those guys.
OK, so that's my estimate.
How many values
can this guy take?
It's a little bit of counting.
Four values.
How did you get to that number?
OK, so each of these guys
can take value 0, 1, right?
So the number of values
that it can take,
I mean, it's a little
annoying, because then I
have to sum them, right?
So basically, I have to
count the number of 1's.
So how many 1's
can I get, right?
Sorry I have to-- yeah, so this
is the number of 1's that I--
OK, so let's look at that.
So we get 0, 0, 0.
0, 0, 1.
And then I get
basically three of them
that have just the
one in there, right?
So there's three of them.
How many of them
have exactly two 1's?
2.
Sorry, 3, right?
So it's just this guy where
I replaced the 0's and the 1.
OK, so now I get--
so here I get three
that take the value 1,
and one that gets the value 0.
And then I get three
that take the value 2,
and then one that
takes the value 1.
The value [? 0 ?] 1's, right?
OK, so everybody knows what I'm
missing here is just the ones
here where I replaced
the 0's by 1's.
So the number of values
that this thing can take
is 1, 2, 3, 4.
So someone is counting
much faster than me.
And so those numbers, you've
probably seen them before,
right?
1, 3, 3, 1, remember?
And so essentially
those guys, it
takes only three values,
which are either 1/3, 1.
Sorry, 1/3.
Oh OK, so it's 0, sorry.
1/3, 2/3, and 1.
Those are the four possible
values you can take.
And so now-- which is
probably much easier
to count like that--
and so now all
I have to tell you
if I want to describe
the distribution
of this probability
of this random variable,
is just the probability
that it takes each
of these values.
So X bar 3 takes the
value 0 probability
that X bar 3 takes the
value 1/3, et cetera.
If I give you each of
these possible values,
then you will be able to know
exactly what the distribution
is, and hopefully maybe
to turn it into something
you can compute.
Now the thing is that
those values will actually
depend on the unknown p.
What is the unknown p here?
What is the
probability that X bar
3 is equal to 0 for example?
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, OK.
So let's write it without
making the computation So 1/8 is
probably not the
right answer, right?
For example, if p is equal to
0, what is this probability?
1.
If p is 1, what is
this probability?
0.
So it will depend on p.
So the probability that
this thing is equal to 0,
is just the probability
that all three of those guys
are equal to 0.
The probability that X1 is equal
to 0, and X2 is equal to 0,
and X3 is equal to 0.
Now my things are
independent, so I
do what I actually
want to do, which
say the probability
of the intersection
is the product of the
probabilities, right?
So it's just the probability
that each of them is equal to 0
to the power of 3.
And the probability that each
of them, or say one of them
is equal to 0, is
just 1 minus p.
And then for this guy I just
get the probability-- well,
it's more complicated, because I
have to decide which one it is.
But those things are
just the probability
of some binomial random
variables, right?
This is just a
binomial, X bar 3.
So if I look at X bar 3,
and then I multiply it by 3,
it's just this sum of
independent Bernoulli's
with parameter p.
So this is actually a binomial
with parameter 3 and p.
And there's tables
for binomials,
and they tell you all this.
Now the thing is I want
to invert this guy, right?
Somehow.
This thing depends on p.
I don't like it, so
I'm going to have
to find ways to get this
things depending on p,
and I could make all
these nasty computations,
and spend hours doing this.
But there's tricks
to go around this.
There's upper bounds.
Just like we just
said, well, maybe I
don't want to solve the
second degree equation in p,
because it's just going to
capture maybe smaller order
terms, right?
Things that maybe won't make
a huge difference numerically.
You can check that in
your problem set one.
Does it make a huge
difference numerically
to solve the second
degree equation,
or to just use the
[INAUDIBLE] p 1
minus p or even to plug
in p hat instead of p.
Those are going to
be the-- problem
set one is to make sure that you
see what magnitude of changes
you get by changing from
one method to the other.
So what I wanted to
go to is something
where we can use
something, which is just
a little more brute force.
So the probability
that-- so here
is this Hoeffding's inequality.
We saw that.
That's what we've
finished on last time.
So Hoeffding's
inequality is actually
one of the most
useful inequalities.
If any one of you is doing
anything really to algorithms,
you've seen that
inequality before.
It's extremely convenient
that it tells you
something about bounded
random variables,
and if you do algorithms
typically with things bounded.
And that's the case of
Bernoulli's random variables,
right?
They're bounded between 0 and 1.
And so when I do
this thing, when
I do Hoeffding's inequality,
what this thing is telling
me is for any given epsilon
here, for any given epsilon,
what is the probability
that Xn bar goes away
from its expectation?
All right, then we saw that it
decreases somewhat similarly
to the way a Gaussian
would look like.
So essentially what Hoeffding's
inequality is telling me, is
that I have this picture, when
I have a Gaussian with mean u,
I know it looks
like this, right?
What Hoeffding's
inequality is telling
me is that if I actually
take the average
of some bounded
random variables,
then their probability
distribution function or maybe
math function-- this thing
might not even have [INAUDIBLE]
the density, but let's think
of it as being a density just
for simplicity-- it's
going to be something
that's going to look like this.
It's going to be
somewhat-- well,
sometimes it's going
to have to escape just
for the sake of
having integral 1.
But it's essentially
telling me that those guys
stay below those guys.
The probability that
Xn bar exceeds mu
is bounded by
something that decays
like to tail of Gaussian.
So really that's the picture
you should have in mind.
When I average bounded
random variables,
I actually have something
that might be really rugged.
It might not be smooth
like a Gaussian,
but I know that it's always
bounded by a Gaussian.
And what's nice about it
is that when I actually
start computing probability
that exceeds some number,
say alpha over 2, then I
know that this I can actually
get a number, which is just--
sorry, the probability
that it exceeds, yeah.
So this number that I
get here is actually
going to be somewhat
smaller, right?
So that's going to be the q
alpha over 2 for the Gaussian,
and that's going to be the--
I don't know, r alpha over
2 for this [? Bernoulli ?]
random variable.
Like q prime or different q.
So I can actually do
this without actually
taking any limits, right?
This is valid for any n.
I don't need to
actually go to infinity.
Now this seems a
bit magical, right?
I mean, I just said
we need n to be,
we discussed that we
wanted n to be larger
than 30 last time for
the central limit theorem
to kick in, and this
one seems to tell me
I can do it for any n.
Now there will be a price to pay
is that I pick up this 2 over b
minus alpha squared.
So that's the variance of the
Gaussian that I have, right?
Sort of.
That's telling me what
the variance should be,
and this is actually
not as nice.
I pick factor 4
compared to the Gaussian
that I would get for that.
So let's try to solve
it for our case.
So I just told you try it.
Did anybody try to do it?
So we started from
this last time, right?
And the reason was
that we could say
that the probability that this
thing exceeds q alpha over 2
is alpha.
So that was using CLT, so let's
just keep it here, and see
what we would do differently.
What Hoeffding tells me is
that the probability that Xn
bar minus--
well, what is mu in this case?
It's p, right?
It's just notation here.
Mu was the average,
but we call it
p in the case of
Bernoulli's, exceeds--
let's just call it
epsilon for a second.
So we said that this
was bounded by what?
So Hoeffding tells me
that this is bounded
by 2 times exponential minus 2.
Now the nice thing is that
I pick up a factor n here,
epsilon squared.
And what is b minus a
squared for the Bernoulli's?
1.
So I don't have a
denominator here.
And I'm going to do
exactly what I did here.
I'm going to set this
guy to be equal to alpha.
So that if I get
alpha here, then that
means that just
solving for epsilon,
I'm going to have some number,
which will play the role of q
alpha over 2, and
then I'm going to be
able to just say that p
is between X bar and minus
epsilon, and X bar
n plus epsilon.
OK, so let's do it.
So we have to
solve the equation.
2 exponential minus 2n
epsilon squared equals alpha,
which means that--
so here I'm going to get,
there's a 2 right here.
So that means that I
get alpha over 2 here.
Then I take the
logs on both sides,
and now let me just write it.
And then I want to
solve for epsilon.
So that means that epsilon
is equal to square root log
q over alpha divided by 2n.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Why is b minus a 1?
Well, let's just look, right?
X lives in the
interval b minus a.
So I can take b to be 25,
and a to be my negative 42.
But I'm going to try to
be as sharp as I can.
All right, so what
is the smallest value
you can think of such that
a Bernoulli random variable
is larger than or
equal to this value?
What values does a Bernoulli
random variable take?
0 and 1.
So it takes values
between 0 and 1.
It just maxes the value.
Actually, this is the
worst possible case
for the Hoeffding inequality.
So now I just get this
one, and so now you
tell me that I have this thing.
So when I solve
this guy over there.
So combining this
thing and this thing
implies that the probability
that p lives between Xn
bar minus square root log 2
over alpha divided by 2n and X
bar plus the square root log
2 over alpha divided by 2n
is equal to?
I mean, is at least.
What is it at least equal to?
Here this controls the
probability of them outside
of this interval, right?
It tells me the probability
that Xn bar is far from p
by more than epsilon.
So there's a probability
that they're actually
outside of the interval
that I just wrote.
So it's 1 minus the probability
of being in the interval.
So this is at least
1 minus alpha.
So I just use the fact that a
probability of the complement
is 1 minus the
probability of the set.
And since I have an upper bound
on the probability of the set,
I have a lower bound on the
probability of the complement.
So now it's a bit different.
Before, we actually wrote
something that was--
so let me get it back.
So if we go back to the example
where we took the [INAUDIBLE]
over p, we got this guy.
q alpha over square root of--
over 2 square root n.
So we had Xn bar plus minus
q alpha over 2 square root n.
Actually, that was q alpha
over 2n, I'm sorry about that.
And so now we have something
that replaces this q alpha,
and it's essentially square
root of 2 log 2 over alpha.
Because if I replace
q alpha by square root
of 2 log 2 over
alpha, I actually
get exactly this thing here.
And so the question is,
what would you guess?
Is this number, this margin,
square root of log 2 over alpha
divided by 2n, is it smaller
or larger than this guy?
q alpha all over 2/3n.
Yes?
Larger.
Everybody agrees with this?
Just qualitatively?
Right, because we just made a
very conservative statement.
We do not use anything.
This is true always.
So it can only be better.
The reason in statistics where
you use those assumptions
that n is large enough, that you
have this independence that you
like so much, and so you can
actually have the central limit
theorem kick in,
all these things
are for you to have
enough assumptions
so that you can actually make
sharper and sharper decisions.
More and more
confident statement.
And that's why there's all
this junk science out there,
because people make too much
assumptions for their own good.
They're saying,
well, let's assume
that everything is the way I
love it, so that I can for sure
any minor change, I
will be able to say
that's because I made an
important scientific discovery
rather than, well, that
was just [INAUDIBLE] OK?
So now here's the fun moment.
And actually let me tell you
why we look at this thing.
So there's actually--
who has seen
different types of convergence
in the probability statistic
class?
[INAUDIBLE] students.
And so there's
different types of--
in the real numbers
there's very simple.
There's one
convergence, Xn turns
to X. To start thinking
about functions,
well, maybe you have
uniform convergence,
you have pointwise convergence.
So if you've done
some real analysis,
you know there's different
types of convergence
you can think of.
And in the convergence
of random variables,
there's also different types,
but for different reasons.
It's just because the
question is, what do you
do with the randomness?
When you see that something
converges to something,
it probably means that
you're willing to tolerate
low probability things happening
or where it doesn't happen,
and on how you
handle those, creates
different types of convergence.
So to be fair, in statistics the
only convergence we care about
is the convergence
in distribution.
That's this one.
The one that comes from
the central limit theorem.
That's actually the weakest
possible you could make.
Which is good, because
that means it's
going to happen more often.
And so why do we
need this thing?
Because the only
thing we really need
to do is to say that
when I start computing
probabilities on
this random variable,
they're going to look
like probabilities
on that random variable.
All right, so for example,
think of the following
two random variables,
x and minus x.
So this is the same
random variable,
and this one is negative.
When I look at those
two random variables,
think of them as a sequence,
a constant sequence.
These two constant sequences
do not go to the same number,
right?
One is plus-- one is x,
the other one is minus x.
So unless x is the random
variable always equal to 0,
those two things are different.
However, when I compute
probabilities on this guy,
and when I compute probabilities
on that guy, they're the same.
Because x and minus x
have the same distribution
just by symmetry of the
gaps in random variables.
And so you can see
this is very weak.
I'm not saying anything about
the two random variables being
close to each other
every time I'm
going to flip my coin, right?
Maybe I'm going to press my
computer and say, what is x?
Well, it's 1.2.
Negative x is going
to be negative 1.2.
Those things are
far apart, and it
doesn't matter, because
in average those things
are going to have the same
probabilities that's happening.
And that's all we care
about in statistics.
You need to realize that
this is what's important,
and why you need to know.
Because you have it really good.
If your problem is you really
care more about convergence
almost surely, which is probably
the strongest you can think of.
So what we're going to do is
talk about different types
of convergence not to
just reflect on the fact
on how our life is good.
It's just that the problem
is that when the convergence
in distribution is so weak that
it cannot do anything I want
with it.
In particular, I cannot
say that if X converges,
Xn converges in distribution,
and Yn converges
in distribution, then Xn plus
Yn converge in distribution
to the sum of their limits.
I cannot do that.
It's just too weak.
Think of this example
and it's preventing you
to do quite a lot of things.
So this is converge in
distribution to sum n 0, 1.
This is converge in
But their sum is 0, and
it's certainly not--
it doesn't look
like the sum of two
independent Gaussian
random variables, right?
And so what we need is to
have stronger conditions here
and there, so that we can
actually put things together.
And we're going to have
more complicated formulas.
One of the formulas,
for example,
is if I replace p by p
hat in this denominator.
We mentioned doing
this at some point.
So I would need that
p hat goes to p,
but I need stronger
than n distributions
so that this happens.
I actually need this to
happen in a stronger sense.
So here are the first two
strongest sense in which
random variables can converge.
The first one is almost surely.
And who has already seen
this notation little omega
when they're talking
about random variables?
All right, so very few.
So this little omega is-- so
what is a random variable?
A random variable is
something that you measure
on something that's random.
So the example I
like to think of
is, if you take a ball
of snow, and put it
in the sun for some time.
You come back.
It's going to have a
random shape, right?
It's going to be a random
blurb of something.
But there's still a bunch of
things you can measure on it.
You can measure its volume.
You can measure its
inner temperature.
You can measure
its surface area.
All these things are
random variables,
but the ball itself is omega.
That's the thing on which
you make your measurement.
And so a random variable is
just a function of those omegas.
Now why do we make all
these things fancy?
Because you cannot
take any function.
This function has to be
what's called measurable,
and there's entire
courses on measure theory,
and not everything
is measurable.
And so that's why you have
to be a little careful
why not everything
is measurable,
because you need some
sort of nice property.
So that the measure
of something,
the union of two things, is less
than the sum of the measures,
things like that.
And so almost surely is telling
you that for most of the balls,
for most of the omegas,
that's the right-hand side.
The probability of omega is
such that those things converge
to each other is
actually equal to 1.
So it tells me that for almost
all omegas, all the omegas,
if I put them together,
I get something
that has probability of 1.
It might be that there are other
ones that have probability 0,
but what it's telling
is that this thing
happens for all possible
realization of the underlying
thing.
That's very strong.
It essentially says
randomness does not matter,
because it's happening always.
Now convergence in
probability allows
you to squeeze a little bit
of probability under the rock.
It tells you I want the
convergence to hold,
but I'm willing to let go
of some little epsilon.
So I'm willing to allow Tn
to be less than epsilon.
Tn minus T to be-- sorry,
to be larger than epsilon.
But the problem is they
want this to go to 0
as well as n goes to
infinity, but for each
n this thing does not
have to be 0, which
is different from here, right?
So this probability
here is fine.
So it's a little weaker, but
it's a slightly different one.
I'm not going to ask you
to learn and show that one
is weaker than the other one.
But just know that these
are two different types.
This one is actually much
easier to check than this one.
Then there's something
called convergence in Lp.
So this one is the fact that
it embodies the following fact.
If I give you a random
variable with mean 0,
and I tell you that its
variance is going to 0, right?
You have a sequence of random
variables, their mean is 0,
their expectation is 0, but
their variance is going to 0.
So think of Gaussian random
variables with mean 0,
and a variance
that shrinks to 0.
And this random variable
converges to a spike at 0,
so it converges to 0, right?
And so what I mean by that is
that to have this convergence,
all I had to tell you was that
the variance was going to 0.
And so in L2 this is really
what it's telling you.
It's telling you, well, if
the variance is going to 0--
well, it's for any
random variable T,
so here what I describe
was for a deterministic.
So Tn goes to a random variable
T. If you look at the square--
the expectation of the square
distance, and it goes to 0.
But you don't have to limit
yourself to the square.
You can take power of three.
You can take power
67.6, power of 9 pi.
You take whatever power you
want, it can be fractional.
It has to be lower than 1, and
that's the convergence in Lp.
But we mostly care
about integer p.
And then here's our star, the
convergence in distribution,
and that's just the
one that tells you
that when I start computing
probabilities on the Tn,
they're going to look very close
to the probabilities on the T.
So that was our Tn with
this guy, for example,
and T was this standard
Gaussian distribution.
Now here, this is
not any probability.
This is just the probability
then less than or equal to x.
But if you remember
your probability class,
if you can compute
those probabilities,
you can compute
any probabilities
just by subtracting and just
building things together.
Well, I need this for all x's,
so I want this for each x,
So you fix x, and then you
make the limit go to infinity.
You make n go to
infinity, and I want
this for the point x's at which
the cumulative distribution
function of T is continuous.
There might be jumps, and that
I don't actually care for those.
All right, so here I mentioned
it for random variables.
If you're interested,
there's also random vectors.
A random vector is just a
table of random variables.
You can talk about
random matrices.
And you can talk about
random whatever you want.
Every time you have
an object that's
just collecting real
numbers, you can just
plug random variables in there.
And so there's all these
definitions that [? extend. ?]
So where I see you
see an absolute value,
we'll see a norm.
Things like this.
So I'm sure this might
look scary a little bit,
but really what we are going to
use is only the last one, which
as you can see is
just telling you
that the probabilities
converge to the probabilities.
But I'm going to need the other
ones every once in a while.
And the reason is,
well, OK, so here I'm
actually going to the
important characterizations
of the convergence
in distribution,
which is R convergence style.
So i converge in
distribution if and only
if for any function that's
continuous and bounded,
when I look at the
expectation of f of Tn,
this converges to the
expectation of f of T. OK,
so this is just those two
things are actually equivalent.
Sometimes it's easier to check
one, easier to check the other,
but in this class you won't
have to prove that something
converges in distribution
other than just combining
our existing
convergence results.
And then the last one which
is equivalent to the above two
is, anybody knows what the
name of this quantity is?
This expectation here?
What is it called?
The characteristic
function, right?
And so this i is the complex
i, and is the complex number.
And so it's
essentially telling me
that, well, rather
than actually looking
at all bounded and continuous
but real functions,
I can actually look
at one specific family
of complex functions, which
are the functions that maps
T to E to the ixT
for x and R. That's
a much smaller
family of functions.
All possible continuous
embedded functions
has many more elements
than just the real element.
And so now I can show that
if I limit myself to do it,
it's actually sufficient.
So those three things are used
all over the literature just
to show things.
In particular, if you're
interested in deep digging
a little more mathematically,
the central limit theorem
is going to be so important.
Maybe you want to read
about how to prove it.
We're not going to
prove it in this class.
There's probably at least five
different ways of proving it,
but the most canonical one, the
one that you find in textbooks,
is the one that actually
uses the third element.
So you just look at the
characteristic function
of the square root of
n Xn bar minus say mu,
and you just expand the thing,
and this is what you get.
And you will see
that in the end,
you will get the characteristic
function of a Gaussian.
Why a Gaussian?
Why does it kick in?
Well, because what is the
characteristic function
of a Gaussian?
Does anybody remember the
characteristic function
of a standard Gaussian?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, well, I mean
there's two pi's and stuff
that goes away, right?
A Gaussian is a random variable.
A characteristic
function is a function,
and so it's not really itself.
It looks like itself.
Anybody knows what
the actual formula is?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
E to the minus?
AUDIENCE: E to the
minus x squared over 2.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Exactly.
E to the minus x squared over 2.
But this x squared
over 2 is actually
just the second order expansion
in the Taylor expansion.
And that's why the
Gaussian is so important.
It's just the second
order Taylor expansion.
And so you can check it out.
I think Terry Tao has
some stuff on his blog,
and there's a bunch
of different proofs.
But if you want to prove
convergence in distribution,
you very likely are going to
use one this three right here.
So let's move on.
This is when I said
that this convergence is
weaker than that convergence.
This is what I meant.
If you have convergence
in one style,
it implies convergence
in the other stuff.
So the first [INAUDIBLE] is that
if Tn converges almost surely,
this a dot s dot
means almost surely,
then it also converges
in probability
and actually the
two limits, which
are this random variable
T, are equal almost surely.
Basically what it means is
that whatever you measure one
is going to be the same that
you measure on the other one.
So that's very strong.
So that means that
convergence almost surely
is stronger than
convergence in probability.
If you're converge in Lp
then you also converge
in Lq for sum q less than p.
So if you converge in L2,
you'll also converge in L1.
If you converge in L67,
you converge in L2.
If you're converge
in L infinity,
you converge in Lp for anything.
And so, again, limits are equal.
And then when you
converge in distribution,
when you converge
in probability,
you also converge
in distribution.
OK, so almost surely
implies probability.
Lp implies probability.
Probability implies
distribution.
And here note that
I did not write,
and the limits are
equal almost surely.
Why?
Because the convergence
in distribution
is actually not telling you
that your random variable
is converging to
another random variable.
It's telling you
that the distribution
of your random variable is
converging to a distribution.
And think of this, guys.
x and minus x.
The central limit
theorem tells me
that I'm converging to some
standard Gaussian distribution,
but am I converging to x or
am I converging to minus x?
It's not well identified.
It's any random variable
that has this distribution.
So there's no way
the limits are equal.
Their distributions are
going to be the same,
but they're not the same limit.
Is that clear for everyone?
So in a way, convergence
in distribution
is really not a convergence
of a random variable
towards another random variable.
It's just telling you
the limiting distribution
of your random
variable [INAUDIBLE]
which is enough for us.
And one thing that's
actually really nice
is this continuous
mapping theorem, which
essentially tells you that--
so this is one of the
theorems that we like,
because they tell
us you can do what
you feel like you want to do.
So if I have Tn that goes to
T, f of Tn goes to f of T,
and this is true for
any of those convergence
except for Lp.
But they have to have f,
which is continuous, otherwise
weird stuff can happen.
So this is going to be
convenient, because here I
don't have X to n minus p.
I have a continuous function.
It's between a linear
function of Xn minus p,
but I could think of like
even crazier stuff to do,
and it would still be true.
If I took the square, it would
converge to something that
looks like its distribution.
It's the same as
the distribution
of a square Gaussian.
So this is a mouthful,
these two slides--
actually this particular
slide is a mouthful.
What I have in my head since
I was pretty much where you're
sitting, is this diagram.
So what it tells me-- so it's
actually voluntarily cropped,
so you can start from
any Lq you want large.
And then as you
decrease the index,
you are actually
implying, implying,
implying until you imply
convergence in probability.
Convergence almost surely
implies convergence
in probability, and everything
goes to the [? sync, ?]
that is convergence
in distribution.
So everything implies
convergence in distribution.
So that's basically rather than
remembering those formulas,
this is really the diagram
you want to remember.
All right, so why do we bother
learning about those things.
That's because of this
limits and operations.
Operations and limits.
If I have a sequence
of real numbers,
and I know that Xn converges
to X and Yn converges to Y,
then I can start doing all
my manipulations and things
are happy.
I can add stuff.
I can multiply stuff.
But it's not true always for
convergence in distribution.
But it is, what's
nice, it's actually
true for convergence
almost surely.
Convergence almost surely
everything is true.
It's just impossible
to make it fail.
But convergence in probability
is not always everything,
but at least you can actually
add stuff and multiply stuff.
And it will still give
you the sum of the n,
and the product of the n.
You can even take the ratio
if V is not 0 of course.
If the limit is not
0, then actually
you need Vn to be not 0 as well.
You can actually prove
this last statement, right?
Because it's a combination
of the first statement
of the second one, and the
continuous mapping theorem.
Because the function
that maps x to 1
over x on everything
but 0, is continuous.
And so 1 over Vn
converges to 1 over V,
and then I can multiply
those two things.
So you actually knew that one.
But really this is
not what matters,
because this is something that
you will do whatever happens.
If I don't tell you you cannot
do it, well, you will do it.
But in general
those things don't
apply to convergence
in distribution
unless the pair itself is known
to converge in distribution.
Remember when I said that
these things apply to vectors,
then you need to actually
say that the vector converges
in distributions to
the limiting factor.
Now this tells
you in particular,
since the cumulative
distribution function is not
defined for vectors,
I would have
to actually use one of the
other distributions, one
of the other criteria,
which is convergence
of characteristic
functions or convergence
of a function of bounded
continuous function
of the random variable.
0.2 or 0.3, but 0.1 is not
going get you anywhere.
But this is something
that's going
to be too hard for us to
deal with, so we're actually
going to rely on the
fact that we have
something that's even better.
There's something
that is waiting for us
at the end of his lecture, which
is called Slutsky's that says
that if V, in this case,
converges in probability
but U converge in distribution,
I can actually still do that.
I actually don't
need both of them
to converge in probability.
I actually need only one of
them to converge in probability
to make this statement.
But two sum.
So let's go to another example.
So I just want to make sure that
we keep on doing statistics.
And every time we're going
to just do a little bit
too much probability, I'm
going to reset the pressure,
and start doing
statistics again.
All right, so assume
you observe the times
the inter-arrival time
of the T at Kendall.
So this is not the arrival time.
It's not like 7:56, 8:15.
No, it's really the
inter-arrival time, right?
So say the next T is
arriving in six minutes.
So let's say [INAUDIBLE] bound.
And so you have this
inter-arrival time.
So those are numbers say,
3, 4, 5, 4, 3, et cetera.
So I have this
sequence of numbers.
So I'm going to
observe this, and I'm
going to try to infer what
is the rate of T's going out
of the station from this.
So I'm going to assume
that these things are
mutually independent.
That's probably not
completely true.
Again, it just means
that what it would mean
is that two consecutive
inter-arrival times are
independent.
I mean, you can make it
independent if you want,
but again, this
independent assumption
is for us to be happy and safe.
Unless someone comes
with overwhelming proof
that it's not independent and
far from being independent,
then yes, you have a problem.
But it might be the fact
that it's actually-- if you
have a T that's one hour late.
If an inter-arrival time is
one hour, then the other T,
either they fixed
it, and it's going
to be just 30 seconds behind,
or they haven't fixed it,
then it's going to be
another hour behind.
So they're not
exactly independent,
but they are when things
work well and approximate.
And so now I need to model
a random variable that's
positive, maybe
not upper bounded.
I mean, people complain
enough that this thing
can be really large.
And so one thing that people
like for inter-arrival times
is exponential distribution.
So that's a positive
random variable.
Looks like an exponential
on the right-hand slide,
on the positive line.
And so it decays
very fast towards 0.
The probability that
you have very large
values exponentially small, and
there's a [INAUDIBLE] lambda
that controls how
exponential is defined.
It's exponential minus
lambda times something.
And so we're going
to assume that they
have the same distribution,
the same random variable.
So they're IID, because
they are independent,
and they're identically
distributed.
They all have this exponential
with parameter lambda,
and I'm going to try to
learn something about lambda.
What is the estimated
value of lambda,
and can I build a confidence
interval for lambda.
So we observe n arrival times.
So as I said, the
mutual independence
is plausible, but not
completely justified.
The fact that
they're exponential
is actually something that
people like in all this what's
called queuing theory.
So exponentials
arise a lot when you
talk about inter-arrival times.
It's not about
the bus, but where
it's very important is call
centers, service, servers where
tasks come, and people
want to know how long it's
going to take to serve a task.
So when I call at
a center, nobody
knows how long I'm going to stay
on the phone with this person.
But it turns out that
empirically exponential
distributions have been
very good at modeling this.
And what it means is
that they're actually--
you have this
memoryless property.
It's kind of crazy if
you think about it.
What does that thing say?
Let's parse it.
That's the probability.
So this is condition on the
fact that T1 is larger than T.
So T1 is just say the
first arrival time.
That means that
conditionally on the fact
that I've been waiting
for the first T, well,
the first [INAUDIBLE].
Well, I should probably-- the
first subway for more than T
conditionally-- so I've been
there T minutes already.
Then the probability that
I wait for s more minutes.
So that's the probability
that T1 is learned,
and the time that we've
already waited plus x.
Given that I've been
waiting for T minutes,
really I wait for
s more minutes,
is actually the probability
that I wait for s minutes total.
It's completely memoryless.
It doesn't remember how
long have you been waiting.
The probability does not change.
You can have waited for
two hours, the probability
that it takes
another 10 minutes is
going to be the
same as if you had
been waiting for zero minutes.
And that's something
that's actually
part of your problem set.
Very easy to compute.
This is just an
analytical property.
And you just
manipulate functions,
and you see that this thing
just happen to be true,
and that's something
that people like.
Because that's also
something that benefit.
And also what we like is
that this thing is positive
almost surely, which is good
when you model arrival times.
To be fair, we're not
going to be that careful.
Because sometimes
we are just going
to assume that something
follows a normal distribution.
And in particular,
I mean, I don't
know if we're going to
go into that details,
but a good thing that you
can model with a Gaussian
distribution are
heights of students.
But technically with
positive probability,
you can have a negative
Gaussian random variable, right?
And the probability being it's
probably 10 to the minus 25,
but it's positive.
But it's good enough
for us for our modeling.
So this thing is nice, but this
is not going to be required.
When you're modeling
positive random variables,
you don't always have to use
positive distributions that are
supported on positive numbers.
You can use distributions
like Gaussian.
So now this exponential
distribution of T1, Tn
they have the same
parameter, and that
means that in average they have
the same inter-arrival time.
So this lambda is
actually the expectation.
And what I'm just saying
is that they're identically
distributed means
that I mean some sort
of a stationary regime,
and it's not always true.
I have to look at a
shorter period of time,
because at rush
hour and 11:00 PM
clearly those average
inter-arrival times
are going to be different
So it means that I am really
focusing maybe on rush hour.
Sorry, I said it's lambda.
It's actually 1 over lambda.
I always mix the two.
All right, so you have
the density of T1.
So f of T is this.
So it's on the
positive real line.
The fact that I have strictly
positive or larger [INAUDIBLE]
to 0 doesn't make
any difference.
So this is the density.
So it's lambda E to the minus
lambda T. The lambda in front
just ensures that
when I integrate
this function between 0
and infinity, I get 1.
And you can see, it decays like
exponential minus lambda T.
So if I were to draw it, it
would just look like this.
So at 0, what
value does it take?
Lambda.
And then I decay like
exponential minus lambda T.
So this is 0, and
this is f of T.
So very small probability
of being very large.
Of course, it depends on lambda.
Now the expectation, you
can compute the expectation
of this thing, right?
So you integrate T
times f of T. This
is part of the little sheet
that I gave you last time.
This is one of the
things you should
be able to do blindfolded.
And then you get the expectation
of T1 is 1 over lambda.
That's what comes out.
So as I actually tell many of
my students, 99% of statistics
is replacing
expectations by averages.
And so what you're tempted to do
is say, well, if in average I'm
supposed to see 1 over lambda,
I have 15 observations.
I'm just going to average
those observations,
and I'm going to see something
that should be close to 1
over lambda.
So statistics is about
replacing averages,
expectations with
averages, and that's we do.
So Tn bar here, which is
the average of the Ti's, is
a pretty good estimator
for 1 over lambda.
So if I want an
estimate for lambda,
then I need to
take 1 over Tn bar.
So here is one estimator.
I did it without much
principle except that I just
want to replace
expectations by averages,
and then I fixed the problem
that I was actually estimating
1 over lambda by lambda.
But you could come up with
other estimators, right?
But let's say this is my way
of getting to that estimator.
Just like I didn't give you
any principled way of getting p
hat, which is Xn bar
in the kiss example.
But that's the
natural way to do it.
Everybody is completely
shocked by this approach?
All right, so let's do this.
So what can I say about the
properties of this estimator
lambda hat?
Well, I know that Tn bar
is going to 1 over lambda
by the law of large number.
It's an average.
It converges to the
expectation both almost surely,
and in probability.
So the first one is the
strong law of large number,
the second one is the
weak law of large number.
I can apply the strong one.
I have enough conditions.
And hence, what do I apply
so that 1 over Tn bar
actually goes to lambda?
So I said hence.
What is hence?
What is it based on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET Yeah,
continuous mapping theorem,
right?
So I have this
function 1 over x.
I just apply this function.
So if it was 1 over
lambda squared,
I would have the
same thing that would
happen just because
the function 1 over x
is continuous away from 0.
And now the central
limit theorem
is also telling me
something about lambda.
About Tn bar, right?
It's telling me that if
I look at my average,
I remove the expectation here.
So if I do Tn bar
minus my expectation,
rescale by this guy here,
then this thing is going
to converge to some
Gaussian random variable,
but here I have this
lambda to the negative 1--
to the negative 2
here, and that's
because they did not
tell you that if you
compute the variance--
so from this, you
can probably extract.
So if I have X that follows
some exponential distribution
with parameter lambda.
Well, let's call it T.
So we know that T in
expectation, the expectation
of T is 1 over lambda.
What is the variance of T?
You should be able to read
it from the thing here.
1 over lambda squared.
That's what you actually
read in the variance,
because the central limit
theorem is really telling you
the distribution
goes through this n.
But this numbers and this
number you can read, right?
If you look at the expectation
of this guy it's-- of this guy
comes out.
This is 1 over lambda
minus 1 over lambda.
That's why you read the 0.
And if you look at the
variance of the dot,
you get n times the
variance of this average.
Variance of the average is
picking up a factor 1 over n.
So the n cancels.
And then I'm left with only
one of the variances, which
is 1 over lambda squared.
OK, so we're not going
to do that in details,
because, again, this is just
a pure calculus exercise.
But this is if you compute
integral of lambda e
to the minus t lambda
times t squared.
Actually t minus 1
over lambda squared
dt between 0 and infinity.
You will see that this thing
is 1 over lambda squared.
How would I do this?
Configuration by
[INAUDIBLE] or you know it.
All right.
So this is what the central
limit theorem tells me.
So this gives me
if I solve this,
and I plug in so I can
multiply by lambda and solve,
it would give me somewhat
a confidence interval for 1
over lambda.
If we just think
of 1 over lambda
as being the p
that I had before,
this would give me a
central limit theorem for--
sorry, a confidence
interval for 1 over lambda.
So I'm hiding a little
bit under the rug
the fact that I have
to still define it.
Let's just actually
go through this.
I see some of you are
uncomfortable with this,
so let's just do it.
So what we've just proved
by the central limit
theorem is that the
probability, that's
square root of n Tn minus 1 over
lambda exceeds q alpha over 2
is approximately
equal to alpha, right?
That's just the statement of
the central limit theorem,
and by approximately equal I
mean as n goes to infinity.
Sorry I did not
write it correctly.
I still have to divide
by square root of 1
over lambda squared, which is
the standard deviation, right?
And we said that
this is a bit ugly.
So let's just do it
the way it should be.
So multiply all these
things by lambda.
So that means now that
the absolute value, so
with probability 1 minus
alpha asymptotically,
I have that square root of
n times lambda Tn minus 1
is less than or equal
to q alpha over 2.
So what it means is that, oh,
I have negative q alpha over 2
less than square root of n.
Let me divide by
square root of n here.
lambda Tn minus
1 q alpha over 2.
And so now what I have is that
I get that lambda is between--
that's Tn bar-- is between
1 plus q alpha over 2
divided by root n.
And the whole thing
is divided by Tn bar,
and same thing on the other side
except I have 1 minus q alpha
over 2 divided by root
n divided by Tn bar.
So it's kind of a weird
shape, but it's still
of the form 1 over Tn bar
plus or minus something.
But this something
depends on Tn bar itself.
And that's actually normal,
because Tn bar is not only
giving me information
about the mean,
but it's also giving me
information about the variance.
So it should definitely come
in the size of my error bars.
And that's the way it comes
in this fairly natural way.
Everybody agrees?
So now I have actually
built a confidence interval.
But what I want to show
you with this example is,
can I translate this
in a central limit
theorem for something that
converges to lambda, right?
I know that Tn bar
converges to 1 over lambda,
but I also know that 1 over
Tn bar converges to lambda.
So do I have a central limit
theorem for 1 over Tn bar?
Technically no, right?
Central limit theorems are about
averages, and 1 over an average
is not an average.
But there's something that
statisticians like a lot,
and it's called
the Delta method.
The Delta method
is really something
that's telling you
that you can actually
take a function of
an average, and let
it go to the function
of the limit,
and you still have a
central limit theorem.
And the factor or the
price to pay for this
is something which depends on
the derivative of the function.
And so let's just
go through this,
and it's, again, just like
the proof of the central limit
theorem.
And actually in many of those
asymptotic statistics results,
this is actually just
a Taylor expansion,
and here it's not
even the second order,
it's actually the
first order, all right?
So I'm just going to do linear
approximation of this function.
So let's do it.
So I have that g of Tn bar--
actually let's use the
notation of this slide,
which is Zn and theta.
So what I know is that Zn
minus theta square root of n
goes to some Gaussian,
this standard Gaussian.
No, not standard.
OK, so that's the assumptions.
And what I want to show is
some convergence of g of Zn
to g of theta.
So I'm not going to
multiply by root n just yet.
So I'm going to do a first
order Taylor expansion.
So what it is telling me is that
this is equal to Zn minus theta
times g prime of,
let's call it theta bar
where theta bar is
somewhere between say
Zn and theta, for sum.
OK, so if theta is less than
Zn you just permute those two.
So that's what the
Taylor first order Taylor
expansion tells me.
There exists a theta bar
that's between the two
values at which I'm expanding
so that those two things are
equal.
Is everybody shocked?
No?
So that's standard
Taylor expansion.
Now I'm going to
multiply by root n.
And so that's going to be what?
That's going to be
root n Zn minus theta.
Ah-ha, that's something I like.
Times g prime of theta bar.
Now the central limit
theorem tells me
that this goes to what?
Well, this goes to sum n
0 sigma squared, right?
That was the first
line over there.
This guy here, well,
it's not clear, right?
Actually it is.
Let's start with this guy.
What does theta bar go to?
Well, I know that Zn
is going to theta.
Just because, well, that's
my law of large numbers.
Zn is going to
theta, which means
that theta bar is sandwiched
between two values that
converge to theta.
So that means that theta bar
converges to theta itself
as n goes to infinity.
That's just the law
of large numbers.
Everybody agrees?
Just because it's
sandwiched, right?
So I have Zn.
I have theta, and theta
bar is somewhere here.
The picture might be reversed.
It might be that Zn end
is larger than theta.
But the law of large
number tells me
that this guy is not moving,
but this guy is moving that way.
So you know when
n is [INAUDIBLE],,
there's very little
wiggle room for theta bar,
and it can only get to theta.
And I call it the
sandwich theorem,
or just find your
favorite food in there.
So this guy goes
to theta, and now I
need to make an extra
assumption, which
is that g prime is continuous.
And if g prime is continuous,
then g prime of theta bar
goes to g prime of theta.
So this thing goes
to g prime of theta.
But I have an issue here.
Is that now I have
something that
converges in distribution
and something
that converges in say--
I mean, this converges almost
surely or saying probability
just to be safe.
And this one converges
in distribution.
And I want to combine them.
But I don't have a
slide that tells me
I'm allowed to take the product
of something that converges
in distribution, and something
that converges in probability.
This does not exist.
Actually, if
anything it told me,
do not do anything with things
that converge in distribution.
And so that gets us to our--
OK, so I'll come back
to this in a second.
And that gets us to something
called Slutsky's theorem.
And Slutsky's theorem tells us
that in very specific cases,
you can do just that.
So you have two sequences
of random variables, Xn bar,
that's Xn that converges to
X. And Yn that converges to Y,
but Y is not anything.
Y is not any random variable.
So X converges in
this distribution.
Sorry, I forgot to mention,
this is very important.
Xn converges in distribution,
Y converges in probability.
And we know that in generality
we cannot combine those two
things, but Slutsky tells
us that if the limit of Y is
a constant, meaning it's
not a random variable,
but it's a
deterministic number 2,
just a fixed number that's
not a random variable,
then you can combine them.
Then you can sum them, and
then you can multiply them.
I mean, actually you can do
whatever combination you want,
because it actually implies
that X, the vector Xn, Yn
converges to the vector Xc.
OK, so here I just
took two combinations.
They are very convenient for
us, the sum and the product
so I could do other
stuff like the ratio
if c is not 0, things like that.
So that's what
Slutsky does for us.
So what you're going to have to
write a lot in your homework,
in your mid-terms, by Slutsky.
I know some people are very
generous with their by Slutsky.
They just do numerical
applications,
mu is equal to 6, and
therefore by Slutsky
mu square is equal to 36.
All right, so don't do that.
Just use, write Slutsky when
you're actually using Slutsky.
But this is something that's
very important for us,
and it turns out
that you're going
to feel like you can write
by Slutsky all the time,
because that's going to
work for us all the time.
Everything we're going
to see is actually
going to be where we're going
to have to combine stuff.
Since we only rely on
convergence from distribution
arising from the
central limit theorem,
we're actually going to have
to rely on something that
allows us to combine them,
and the only thing we know
is Slutsky.
So we better hope
that this thing works.
So why Slutsky works for us.
Can somebody tell
me why Slutsky works
to combine those two guys?
So this one is converging
in distribution.
This one is converging
in probability,
but to a deterministic number.
g prime of theta is a
deterministic number.
I don't know what theta is, but
it's certainly deterministic.
All right, so I can combine
them, multiply them.
So that's just the second
line of that in particular.
All right, everybody is with me?
So now I'm allowed to do this.
You can actually--
you will see something
like counterexample
questions in your problem
set just so that you
can convince yourself.
It's always a good thing.
I don't like to
give them, because I
think it's much better
for you to actually come
to the counterexample yourself.
Like what can go wrong
if Y is not a random--
sorry, if Y is not a--
sorry, if c is not the constant,
but it's a random variable.
You can figure that out.
All right, so let's go back.
So we have now this Delta
method that tells us
that now I have a
central limit theorem
for functions of averages,
and not just for averages.
So the only price to pay
is this derivative there.
So, for example, if g is
just a linear function,
then I'm going to have a
constant multiplication.
If g is a quadratic
function, then I'm
going to have theta squared
that shows up there.
Things like that.
So just think of what
kind of applications
you could have for this.
Here are the functions
that we're interested in,
is x maps to 1 over x.
What is the derivative
of this guy?
of 1 over x?
Negative 1 over
x squared, right?
That's the thing we're going
to have to put in there.
And so this is what we get.
So now when I'm actually
going to write this,
so if I want to show square root
of n lambda hat minus lambda.
That's my application, right?
This is actually 1 over Tn, and
this is 1 over 1 over lambda.
So the function g of x
is 1 over x in this case.
So now I have this thing.
So I know that by
the Delta method--
oh, and I knew
that Tn, remember,
square root of Tn
minus 1 over lambda
was going to sum
normal with mean 0
and variance 1 over
lambda squared, right?
So the sigma square over there
is 1 over lambda squared.
So now this thing goes to what?
Sum normal.
What is going to be the mean?
0.
And what is the variance?
So the variance is going--
I'm going to pick up
this guy, 1 over lambda
squared, and then I'm going to
have to take g prime of what?
Of 1 over lambda, right?
That's my theta.
So I have g of theta,
which is 1 over theta.
So I'm going to have g
prime of 1 over lambda.
And what is g prime
of 1 over lambda?
So we said that g prime is 1
over negative 1 over x squared.
So it's negative 1 over
1 over lambda squared--
sorry, squared.
Which is nice, because
g can be decreasing.
So that would be annoying
to have a negative variance.
And so g prime is
negative 1 over, and so
what I get eventually is
lambda squared up here,
but then I square it again.
So this whole thing
here becomes what?
Can somebody tell me
what the final result is?
Lambda squared right?
So it's lambda 4
divided by lambda 2.
So that's what's written there.
And now I can just do my
good old computation for a--
I can do a good computation
for a confidence interval.
All right, so let's just
go from the second line.
So we know that lambda
hat minus lambda
is less than, we've done
that several times already.
So it's q alpha over 2--
sorry, I should put alpha
over 2 over this thing, right?
So that's really the quintile
of what our alpha over 2 times
lambda divided by
square root of n.
All right, and so that means
that my confidence interval
should be this, lambda hat.
Lambda belongs to lambda
plus or minus q alpha
over 2 lambda divided
by root n, right?
So that's my
confidence interval.
But again, it's not
very suitable, because--
sorry, that's lambda hat.
Because they don't
know how to compute it.
So now I'm going to
request from the audience
some remedies for this.
What do you suggest we do?
What is the laziest
thing I can do?
Anybody?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET Replace
lambda by lambda hat.
What justifies
for me to do this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET
Yeah, and Slutsky
tells me I can actually do
it, because Slutsky tells me,
where does this lambda
come from, right?
This lambda comes from here.
That's the one that's here.
So actually I could
rewrite this entire thing
as square root of n lambda hat
minus lambda divided by lambda
converges to sum n 0, 1.
Now if I replace this by
lambda hat, what I have is
that this is actually really
the original one times
lambda divided by lambda hat.
And this converges
to n 0, 1, right?
And now what you're telling
me is, well, this guy
I know it converges to n 0, 1,
and this guy is converging to 1
by the law of large number.
But this one is converging to 1,
which happens to be a constant.
It converges in probability,
so by Slutsky I can actually
take the product and still
maintain my conversion
to distribution to
a standard Gaussian.
So you can always do this.
Every time you replace
some p by p hat,
as long as their
ratio goes to 1,
which is going to be guaranteed
by the law of large number,
you're actually
going to be fine.
And that's where we're
going to use Slutsky a lot.
When we do plug in, Slutsky
is going to be our friend.
OK, so we can do this.
And that's one way.
And then other
ways to just solve
for lambda like we did before.
So the first one we
got is actually--
I don't know if I still
have it somewhere.
Yeah, that was the one, right?
So we had 1 over Tn q, and
that's exactly the same
that we have here.
So your solution is actually
giving us exactly this guy when
we actually solve for lambda.
So this is what we get.
Lambda hat.
We replace lambda by
lambda hat, and we
have our asymptotic
convergence theorem.
And that's exactly what we
did in Slutsky's theorem.
Now we're getting to it at
this point is just telling us
that we can actually do this.
Are there any questions
about what we did here?
So this derivation right
here is exactly what I
did on the board I showed you.
So let me just show you
with a little more space
just so that we all
understand, right?
So we know that square root of n
lambda hat minus lambda divided
by lambda, the
true lambda defined
converges to sum n 0, 1.
So that was CLT
plus Delta method.
Applying those two,
we got to here.
And we know that
lambda hat converges
to lambda in probability and
almost surely, and that's what?
That was law of large number
plus continued mapping theorem,
right?
Because we only knew that
one of our lambda hat
converges to 1 over lambda.
So we had to flip
those things around.
And now what I said is
that I apply Slutsky,
so I write square root of n
lambda hat minus lambda divided
by lambda hat, which is the
suggestion that was made to me.
They said, I want
this, but I would
want to show that it
converges to sum n 0,
1 so I can legitimately use
q alpha over 2 in this one
though.
And the way we said is like,
well, this thing is actually
really q divided by lambda times
lambda divided by lambda hat.
So this thing that
was proposed to me,
I can decompose
it in the product
of those two random variables.
The first one here converges
through the Gaussian
from the central limit theorem.
And the second one converges
to 1 from this guy,
but in probability this time.
That was the ratio of two
things in probability,
we can actually get it.
And so now I apply Slutsky.
And Slutsky tells me that
I can actually do that.
But when I take the product
of this thing that converges
to some standard Gaussian,
and this thing that converges
in probability to 1, then
their product actually
converges to still this
standard Gaussian [INAUDIBLE]
Well, that's exactly
what's done here,
and I think I'm getting there.
So in our case, OK, so just a
remark for Slutsky's theorem.
So that's the last line.
So in the first example we used
the problem dependent trick,
which was to say,
well, turns out
that we knew that p
is between 0 and 1.
So we have this p 1 minus
p that was annoying to us.
We just said, let's
just bound it by 1/4,
because that's going to be
true for any value of p.
But here, lambda takes any
value between 0 and infinity,
so we didn't have such a trick.
It's something like we could
see that lambda was less
than something.
Maybe we know it, in which
case we could use that.
But then in this case,
we could actually also
have used Slutsky's theorem
by doing plug in, right?
So here this is my p 1 minus
p that's replaced by p hat 1
minus p hat.
And Slutsky justify,
so we did that
without really
thinking last time.
But Slutsky actually
justifies the fact
that this is valid, and
still allows me to use
this q alpha over 2 here.
All right, so that's
the end of this lecture.
Tonight I will post the next
set of slides, chapter two.
And, well, hopefully the video.
I'm not sure when it's
going to come out.